LAST GAME BUT HE HAS BEENacKINNA
S
BUMPS IT FOR MacKINNON.
HERE HE COMES THROU NOW GOT 14 .
SCORE!
[ HORN ]
>> MIKKO RANTANEN THROWS IT OFF
MOSE, I
[ HORN ]
>> DID ALEX NEWHOOK, A QUICK
LITTLE TURNAROUND THAT
EXTRA CONFIDENCE THAT HE WAS HI.
ALL THE WAY TO THE AVALANCHE
CREASE AND HE'S ABLE TO DUMP ITD
FIALA, WHO HAD A COUPLE OF GREAR
MAKAR.
ONE SHOHO
YOU KNOW, WHEN KADRI.
LOGAN O'CONNOROR SAVE -- SCORE.
OH, NO!
KAPRIZOV THREW IT AT THE FRONT.
NET AND THAT SHOT
TO BE ABLE TO GET THAT ON NET.G.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THEY ARE NOT
>> WELL, IF IT'S UNDERNEATH THE
SCATHE, ABSOLUTELY
ATTACKER GOAL HAS TIED THE GAME
3-3.
THE AVS COULDN'T CLEAR THEE.
HERE WEIKKO.
>> PICKS IT UP.
INTO THE AVALANCHE ZONE.
ZUCCARELLO ENTERS THE
GLOVE.
N.
SPEED DOWN SHOT, HE SHOOTS
AND HE SCORES!
[ HORN ]
>> MIKKO RANTANEN!N!
SHOOTOUT!
LEAGUE CAREER!
[ HORN ]
>> DID THE AVALANCHE BEAT THE